so in evolution right most things that
kind of look alike are connected but
there's this other thing where things
keep evolving independently into crabs
because being a crab is such an
evolutionarily advantageous position
it's like why a lot of things would lead
you to want to ultimately be a crap
what's so good about being a crowd
you're protected you have a legs I think
those are the main ones
yeah does that mean that we're all Gonna
Be You Gotta basically have to watch out
that you don't involve into doing yeah
but I do sometimes feel yeah yeah like
the urge to like weird sort of
crustacean urges exactly you can feel
the clamping yeah exactly yeah yeah a
crab that wouldn't strike me as the most
evolutionary advantageous I know exactly
like they're so [__] easy to rip
apart you know